[Music]
Disney Princesses are extremely
admirable but let's be honest they don't
always make the best decisions we have
beef with one specific princess
throughout this script stay tuned to
find out who it is don't forget to hit
that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out the worst Disney
princess moments when Ariel trusted
Ursula let's start with one of the most
frustrating moments ever Ariel was so
crazily in love with Eric she really
didn't care about any villains in that
movie in fact she was totally ready to
make a pact with Ursula and sell her
soul without even thinking about it
seriously
Ariel showed some pretty terrible signs
of obsessive behavior come on Ursula is
clearly the bad guy and Ariel has no
issues talking it over with her for the
sake of being with Eric romantic maybe
obsessive definitely no matter how much
you want a man don't ever do this when
mogera fell in love twice falling in
love is an amazing experience that
changes you forever nothing wrong with
that right well in mcGarry's case
falling in love also meant sacrificing
herself for a man seriously what is up
with Disney first time the gara made
this mistake when she had to make that
deal with Hades to save a man's life and
the second time is of course with
Hercules Disney men just have a huge ego
especially if their gods going after
Hercules didn't do Meg any favors
whatsoever if we ever get a live action
we want her to stay away what those Elsa
turning her back on everyone we'll talk
more about else's mistake in just a bit
but the first one was definitely turning
her back on everyone while this
definitely happens to people in real
life it just shows how damaging it can
be by isolating herself Elsa pretty much
set herself to a miserable life for all
those years we're glad she eventually
learns to let it go
she definitely showed how important it
is to surround yourself with people that
love you for who you are even if you
the ice queen Rapunzel getting persuaded
by Mother Gothel plenty of people have
noticed said Mother Gothel is displaying
some pretty severe narcissistic traits
she obviously loves herself and
Rapunzel's hair more than actual
Rapunzel and she just wants to keep her
so-called daughter for her powers but
because she's so manipulative it makes
it that much harder for Rapunzel to
steer clear of her mother but still one
of the worst decisions was to never
leave that tower when Mother Gothel went
away of course it's not her fault as she
was basically held hostage but in our
ideal world Rapunzel uses that pin on
Mother Gothel and swings as hard as
possible Jasmine was okay with getting
catfished we all loved Aladdin right
he's the cutest but here's the problem
he basically lied to Jasmine sure she
still fell in love with him and Disney
managed to pull the good ole it's the
inside what matters line but doesn't
this basically just teach girls and it's
okay to get catfished Aladdin clearly
wasn't who he said he was and she was
totally okay with it it doesn't always
work out that way guys really this is
just an overall terrible decision
because it leads to a terrible message
and if you've seen the show catfish you
know that these type of things rarely
work out in real life changing your man
let's take a break from being too hard
on Disney Princesses and talk about a
general thing that's pretty disturbing
and kind of disappointing of course you
should always strive to be better but
not at the expense of completely
changing your qualities you know who
we're talking about and were honestly so
frustrated with her we won't even
mention her name if your man wants you
to change absolutely everything about
you to fit his own needs you should find
a new one Moana leaving puah behinds we
understand why she did this we really do
since puo went on that first adventure
that ended up with Moana getting injured
he stayed behind there was absolutely no
mention of why Moana didn't even
consider bringing him onboard
promotional posters all include puah and
we still think Moana made her worst
decision when she left him behind come
on who would you rather have on board
puah or hey hey we were robbed from
seeing Maui and puah interacts we
totally understand why she did it but
come on Moana Elsa lyin to Anna we
already spoke about Elsa turning her
back on pretty much everyone the one of
her worst decisions was when she lied to
Anna Anna would have probably been
better off knowing about Elsa's
condition all this time sure Elsa hurt
her when they were kids but come on it
was an accident it's way worse to leave
Anna completely isolated and without
that precious sisterly bond of course
Elsa learned this was a mistake later on
but seriously Anna was completely
oblivious to everything for years
bocahantas messing around with John
Pocahontas is just one of those stories
that's totally different from the
original and if you haven't heard about
the original you should check out some
of our other Disney related videos but
anyways Pocahontas and messing around
with John Smith was so unnecessary she
really should have listened to her
father when he told her to stay away
from white men sometimes dads really
know best don't they we disapprove of
the John Smith romance just as much as
her dad does
but seriously if you are not a fan of
the actual movie story you should check
out what happened to Pocahontas in real
life his patches what are we trying to
say beggar no let's work with me here
we're much though alienating herself but
it's not just Elsa who alienated herself
Belle did it too she just buried her
nose and books and did absolutely
nothing else getting lost in fairy tales
is good but you also need to balance
things out Belle basically went from
being an always at home introvert to
immediately falling in love what about
the in-between she should have seen more
of life of course it wasn't her choice
to get trapped in that castle but that
village alone looked like a fun place to
hang out at and Belle should have taken
advantage of that sometimes you just
have to get out of your comfort zone and
see what's out there
why does everyone ignore genuinely good
advice let's talk about some general
things that are really frustrating when
it comes to Disney Princesses almost
every Disney Princesses basically sort
of independent but a lot of them just
either ignore or refused to follow good
advice
take Pocahontas for example her dad had
a point by forbidding her to hang out
with the Whiteman
Ariel should also listen to her dad a
bit more even Moana had to admit Maui
made a point a couple of times not
wearing casual clothes
in wreck-it Ralph to slumber party
trailer scene it's one of the best
moments of the movie even though the
movie isn't even out yet but one of the
worst things about Disney Princesses is
the fact that they're always in their
fancy dresses seriously let your hair
down and put on something casual it
feels amazing
and those record Ralph's casual outfits
are literally the best things we've ever
seen Mulan's definitely our fave but
they all look absolutely amazing Disney
Princesses always look fancy but the
samba party scene really gives them that
girl-next-door look seriously their
relationships with men apart from maybe
Moana and Maui there are very few Disney
Princesses that have a normal
relationship or friendship with men
they're always in need of saving you and
you know we're still eyeing the one
Disney Princess that pretty much half
destroyed herself for a man it's not
healthy guys we've really need more
male-female dynamics that don't just
revolve around love and bonus points as
men are also human and not pets or
animal sidekicks seriously haven't all
sidekicks been male we can't think of a
single female character that took the
role of a Disney Princess sidekick which
brings us to the next point
playing the damsel in distress Disney
has seen a lot of raise eyebrows for
their portrayal of Disney Princess
characters and playing damsels in
distress is definitely one of them were
sure this was totally normal a couple of
decades ago but we're glad Disney
finally moved away from that with a few
recent Disney princess movie releases
but one of their worst decisions was
definitely the damsel in distress
angle not everyone wants to be saved
some princesses want to lead wara not
being more assertive Aurora just kind of
blended in the background and gave in to
her fate didn't she sure she was an old
character and she belonged to the old
Disney stereotype but come on we
definitely expected more from her but
she basically just wasn't assertive at
all she just followed the curse and
fulfilled it if this was modern Disney
we'd probably see Aurora do everything
she possibly could to save herself and
that's exactly how you know that her
timid personality was a mistake we call
for a Sleeping Beauty - so Aurora can
finally redeem herself Winston
mirela was too submissive it's not just
a rora that never stood up for herself
Cinderella was also way too submissive
and obedient she didn't have to be
but of course around that time everyone
wanted to see obedient children but
Cinderella didn't Oh her so-called
family anything her behavior really
shows a lack of character development as
she never really stood up for herself
she just kind of accepted her role and
didn't disobey her stepmothers commands
once seriously we're glad that Disney
moved to a different portrayal of Disney
princess characters Snow White's escape
says no white met the dwarfs because she
was running away from the Huntsman but
if you think about it she really didn't
have to run away a modern-day Disney
Princess would stand up to the Huntsman
and have a few things to say if this was
Rapunzel she'd used her frying pan but
one of the weirdest decisions made by
Snow White comes from the fact that she
ran in the strangers house and not just
any stranger 7 weird-looking men
we're glad this is Disney and not
Stephen King because the whole situation
would have ended badly almost always
looking for Prince Charming let's be
honest there are only a few Disney
Princesses who proved they don't need a
man in their lives while there's nothing
wrong with searching for love it feels
like it's a frequent theme in almost
every Disney movie and all princesses do
is dream of their prince charmings
because let's be honest they get saved
by men a lot this is one of those things
were so glad Disney moved away from it
was about time we got another storyline
rights bail falling in love with her
captor Belle was trapped in beasts
castle over the years a common theory
was spotted about Beauty and the Beast
and a sub fell basically fell in love
with her captor which means she had
Stockholm Syndrome
the theory was since debunked by plenty
of people including Emma Watson but it
still rubs us the wrong way that Belle
basically had no choice but to fall in
love with her captor sure beasts turned
out to be lovely and Disney gave the
story a lesson that beauty lies on the
inside sure it does but that beauty was
also put in a castle against her own
will
Arielle giving up her own voice
seriously we have a huge beef with Ariel
girl come on you can do better than that
we get that living underwater can be
pretty boring but she was just so ready
to do whatever it takes to be with Eric
this includes giving up her own voice
which is
pretty extreme especially since Ariel
had an absolutely lovely voice The
Little Mermaid is an adorable story but
let's be honest Ariel
really should have listened to her
father or found a different way to see
the mainland what do you dislike about
the Disney Princesses come let us know
in the comments and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]